a forceful and unexpected challenge to
President Trump is coming from inside
his cabinet Attorney General William Bar
says the president's social media habits
make it quote impossible for him to do
his job in a new interview the Attorney
General said the president should quote
stop tweeting and quote about Justice
Department cases bars comments come a
few days after he reversed his own
prosecutors request for a long prison
term for Roger stone a longtime ally of
the President Democrats are demanding an
investigation men Tracy's at the White
House for us good morning band so bars
clearly sending a message here how are
the president and other officials
responding good morning was pretty clear
a lot of people here at the White House
were caught off guard by bars
extraordinary comments but the White
House claims President Trump himself
he's not bothered by this at all and
that he still has confidence in his
Attorney General I cannot do my job here
at the department with a constant
background commentary that undercuts me
the Attorney General fires a warning
shot telling President Trump to stop
attacking the Justice Department to have
public statements and tweets made about
the department make it impossible for me
to do my job
bar claims he never discussed the Roger
stone case with the White House and says
he decided on his own to overrule
prosecutors on the case before the
president tweeted that their request of
a 79 year sentence for stone was very
unfair and a miscarriage of justice
once the tweet occurred the question as
well now what do I do
and do you go forward with what you
think is the right decision or do you
pull back because of the tweet and that
just sort of illustrates how disruptive
these tweets can be Barr rarely speaks
out against mr. Trump who he's been
criticized of protecting too much but
his comments come as he's facing a
potential rebellion inside the
Department of Justice Barr got support
from the Senate's
top Republican the Attorney General says
it's getting in the way of doing his job
maybe the president should listen to the
attorney job and while others defended
the president he's not interfering what
he did was make a comment about
what he saw was wrong and so there's no
interference President Trump is also
taking hits from his former chief of
staff John Kelly who this week publicly
defended Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
VIN Minh the national security staffer
who raised concerns about president
Trump's phone call with the president of
Ukraine the president fired back at
Kelly on Twitter saying that he misses
the action and can't keep his mouth shut
but there is some good news for the
president hope Hicks one of the
president's most loyal and trusted aides
is returning to the White House after
leaving her job here as communications
director nearly two years ago
this time Hicks will be working with the
president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
she'll have the lofty title of counselor
to the president Jericka alright Ben
thank you